the Joe Rogan experience as you're
examining this have you gone back and
forth on this have you had like opinions
that you abandoned her yeah yeah well so
I'll tell you one the one that that I
think I really struggled with her ad
that surprised me big time was people
always try to get me to say it's child
abuse to put your kid on puberty
blockers and whatnot it's child to be as
the parents are committing child abuse
and I don't say that and I don't say
that for a reason because I'm
interviewed the parents and once you
interview parents of people kids that
you know parents who have transitioned
their kids you you start talking them
and you realize that they thought they
were doing what was right for their kid
they were really scared they didn't know
like they're very concerned I mean it's
third they're worried and they've been
encouraged by mental help Mel to health
professionals who should have been
looking out for the child that if you
don't do this your child could kill him
could kill herself or himself you know
and that's terrifying
and sometimes I'll bring up the risks
with them and they won't have heard
about them I'll say but you know just
just checking with you you know what
what about the long-term you know maybe
you're foreclosing orgasm like you're if
your kid goes through all this and goes
on the you know you know that to
testosterone and then goes you know gets
the surgeries you because they never
went through normal puberty they may
never experience orgasm what about that
and they'll never have heard of that or
you know we're putting so many
capacities at risk well there's there's
a real problem with the way people are
willing to discuss things that they're
not willing to in any way address the
negative aspects of transitioning and
one of the one of the things about
hormone blockers that drove me mad was
they were trying to say that you could
put a child on hormone blockers and if
the child changed their mind there would
be no problem whatsoever
well they've reversed that they've
reversed that in the England in England
they reverse reverse in America too they
were very recently there was something
that got released where they were saying
well this is absolutely not true well
this is something that people have said
over and over over an aggressive people
in particular right a totally neutral
intervention just they've said yeah
what's hey let me relieve you of any of
the stress about this because we know
that there'll be no problem at all you
can transition right back but you can't
that's
not true you it'll affect your
development that's right and and
hormones shower the brain and there's
just you know and you know there's right
I've talked to a lot of experts but I've
also talked to parents who were never
told about this you know and so I don't
blame them like I just I just if you're
a parent like how do you know whether
your kid is in this contagion as you put
it or your kid is actually trans like
how do you know and how would anyone
know how would the person that's
transitioning themselves how would they
know right so there's symptoms in the
DSM that have evolved persistent
consistent and insistent severe
discomfort and a two year old and four
year old doesn't keep his you know
feelings to himself if he hates being a
boy insists that he's really a girl is
punching his you know penis and whatever
it's not something parents are not a
generalization because people vary
widely in the way they they deal with
things that bother them right so I think
that the DSM is a list of
generalizations about different mental
health disorders and different
afflictions right with that when you're
talking about a boy hating their penis
and the way they react they'll let you
know not everybody lets you know when
they're in agony and pain or kids
preschool age kids are pretty in a
typical family where there's not you
know been abuse or mistrust or whatever
you know kids pretty much announced it
in my experience and now it's almost
everything I mean they're really open I
hate this that whatever they you know
it's not the kind of thing a parent
won't know hmm
but do you think that kids should be on
hormone blockers i I don't I have never
look I'm a journalist so I explored I
talked to everybody and I explore every
side of every issue and I I think that
hormone blockers are really significant
interventions they can be dangerous we
don't fully have a handle on the
long-term effects but am i someone who
believes they should be totally banned I
you know I have never said that I've
never taken that a position because a
lot of psychologists that I really
respect haven't said that a lot of
doctors that I respect haven't said that
there's no one they could help
could you imagine that those doctors and
psychologists would be
in fear of expressing that they don't
think it's a good idea the same way you
were discussing therapists will secretly
talk to you about the problems of them
expressing themselves honestly right I
mean this is how I see it like say
there's one kid who can be helped by
puberty blockers until I mean I explored
a lot of these issues with a lot of
people until you know psychologists I
respect people who've been very open on
a lot of this stuff until they tell me
there's no children who could ever be
helped by puberty blockers I'm not
someone who will come out in favor of a
ban a banding I don't understand but
that that begs the question how would
one know whether your kid is the kid
that could be beneficial they could
benefit from puberty blockers versus one
who you really should just let become an
adult and go through all the various
changes that children go through
remember that most kids outgrow this so
what I'm not right so not doing anything
not doing a major intervention is
probably in many cases a totally safe
bet in other words you don't have to go
in there and immediately I mean part of
what's crazy about our age is we think
the moment you're in our kids are in
distress we need to medicate them they
can never be upset right we are you know
pushing this accommodation of every
discomfort and every right everything
our kids say
[Applause]